[Music]
[Applause]
seton what's the poll question and did
uh we change it in hour two or hour
three
well we've actually had two poll
questions going for most of the show
okay double dipping yeah yeah we're
double dipping today uh would you rather
miss the playoffs or get swept in the
first round but this is interesting
because 65
of our twitter audience says miss the
playoffs whereas the danpatric.com poll
question that audience yeah 50 50. well
let me ask nick wright that first
thing's first co-host on fox sports one
would you rather be the lakers or the
nets
well those are two different questions i
think making the playoffs is better than
missing the playoffs however
i'd rather be the lakers than the nets
because the lakers you at least had time
to process that this was going to be a
disaster the nets
were the vegas favorites to win the
conference 14 days ago
the nets had many of our colleagues
buying into this nonsense
is five days ago so the nets are a
bigger failure a bigger disappointment
but i i they did you know so so the nets
it was worse but in the
vagaries i've missed the playoffs or get
swept in round one i'd rather get swept
around one i'd like to get there it's
similar to i'd rather you know make the
finals and lose than lose before the
finals and then say oh never lost you
know but that's about a different guy
uh i'll get to more nba we we were
talking about six years ago tonight uh
it was uh what laramie tunsil
with the mask yeah the bong here
yeah
and i was wondering what it would be
like to you know thursday night
if that would happen like six years
later
how do you think we would view you know
let's say i don't want to say a
quarterback because we view a
quarterback differently but let's say
it's an offensive lineman and that video
came out
how do you think the media i don't think
it'd be viewed that differently oh
really
yeah well he dropped because
yeah i think he'd drop again today i i
think i think because there were so many
it wasn't just the gas mask bong it was
that it was from his twitter account and
it's like wait he's being extorted oh
this seems messy and scary yeah i don't
think
listen i understand that in most
municipalities that are listening right
now you can smoke a joint on the street
these days i still feel like
there is still a bit of a
uh you know
some social mores where it hasn't been
fully accepted like you on your show dan
you guys have drank beers i know you
have i've seen you do it would you would
you ever smoke a joint on the air i
don't think you would even if you were i
don't know if you're a weed smoker or
not but regardless like i still think
there is
there is still some stigma attached to
it i think he'd still drop quite a bit
yeah i just don't see that happening now
um
as much because the nfl has relaxed its
standards or whatever on on marijuana
um
so i i mean they don't really care about
these players i don't really think they
he dropped because people were like oh
he's a pothead i think he dropped
because they were like ah character
issues bad judgment who's surrounding
him and i think those same things like
let me put it like this there's not a
lot of stigma i don't think surrounding
uh consensual sex between adults but if
on draft night somebody's twitter posted
a sex video of themselves i think they'd
drop
and i think it'd be like oh we're
worried he's going to be having sex i
think it'd be like well what the hell is
going on here
so i just i'm looking at it differently
fair point
let's move on
okay listen you bring me here for hard
truths i thought we were ranking players
in nba history instead we're talking you
may be talking about sex videos yeah you
don't need to say hard truth um
the nets situation as they move forward
you got the the kyrie
you know max deal uh ben simmons
uh katie getting older and and did look
a little older with the younger guys in
boston
right yeah okay i'm happy for kyrie
by the way worst year of his
professional life and he gave himself a
raise and a promotion how about that
kyrie asked after the game kyrie signs
in boston's making around 34 million a
year
a year into it he's like by the way i'm
co-head coach it's like steve nash is
here but i'm kind of the coach kd's kind
of the coach a year later he's like okay
this year i barely showed up for work i
was terrible in the post season here's
what i've decided i'm going to make
about 45 million a year and i'm
co-general manager i'm going to build
the roster with joe sai and sean marks
this dude is delusional man delusional
i'll ask your audience put this on your
poll question what's your favorite kyrie
irving playoff moment that doesn't
involve lebron james i'll wait yeah i
think it's in round one stomping on that
stupid leprechaun yeah i think that's as
good as it's ever gotten for him
but they're stuck with him
they got to pay him this money
yeah i i feel i mean i
i feel terribly for durant i mean i i i
do and i don't but yeah i mean they're
screwed i mean they are screwed man like
really
what choice do you have you can't let
them walk
yeah it'd be like oh they'll sign him
and then trade him i reported nine
months ago and i was correct on it that
when the nets were considering trading
kyrie he made it very clear so you trade
me if you want but i'll retire that kind
of hurts your trade market so what are
you gonna do
i i know uh our colleague stephen a has
been saying he would pay him the max but
only one year at a time
kyrie ain't going to take a one-year
deal
i mean kind of like they listen and by
the way now that he's code gm i think he
negotiates with himself i think he says
kyrie open your third eye what contract
would you like like uh three years plus
player option of the max like you know
what guy i think we can do that
hopefully you show up for more than 30
games so what do you do with ben simmons
feels like you stuck with him as well
oh boy
all right can i i don't know if this is
a defense of ben simmons can i
can i
soft launch a take sure
i believe ben simmons back is truly hurt
and i believe he didn't suffer a back
injury
i think we know enough about the mind
psycho
yes
stress and anxiety can cause ulcers can
cause back pain among other things so i
don't this idea he's faking an injury i
do not bite him
i believe that his back hurts that he
feels like he has an injury but i also
don't think he ever suffered an injury
does that does that make sense and i
don't think that's like a a scurrilous
allegation it's the only thing that
tracks to me i do think he wants to play
basketball at some point but i think
he's so deep in his own head i think it
scares and i think it is causing the
back pain
i just think the nets handled it so
poorly instead of having one voice and
steve nash should have said at every
press conference
ben is not playing
ben is not playing now ben didn't help
out by saying you know i can't play in
game three but you know there's a
reasonable chance i could play in game
four
you know one voice
because you're not sure who's telling
you the truth and and who's not
i didn't have a lot of sympathy for nash
this year because i thought he did a
truly terrible job um but in this one i
feel terrible for him the hell is he
supposed to do and nash was pretty
consistent with it but then wojo shams
would be like hey ben simmons targeting
this state targeting medic be like what
the hell is going on here
uh yeah that that's a mess
um so i don't know i mean who would leak
that i missed the whole year who would
leak that nick to i have a theory
i have another theory oh boy
this is okay you know what my true north
is take integrity even if this gets me
some angry texts i don't know this and i
can't prove this obviously i wonder
if people close to ben
we're trying to
add pressure in a positive way to get
him on the court
does that make sense yeah that if that
if it's okay he might play he might not
play we think he should play we think
it's good for him to play if we if we
help put out there oh there is a date
that maybe that will get him on the
court and that's his get back on the
horse moment and then his career can
finally turn the page because the reason
this is such a disaster is even if he
plays game one of next year
so many of these questions and concerns
are going to come back the moment the
playoffs start because his last moment
in the play didn't get 10 minutes in
these playoffs his last moment in the
playoffs was the worst moment in his
professional life it's not great
yeah i mentioned that yesterday that
maybe somebody was trying to
not goad him into playing but
trying to push him into come on let's go
let's
let's get back on the horse here and
like i did with the with the dinner
invites just keep subtly bringing it up
until you feel obligated to eventually
do it yeah exactly that strategy but my
back was hurting when we went to dinner
as well yeah i i know you're
self-medicated too buddy but oh my god i
didn't get a sip of that wine but i do
i do make my free throws
you do make your free throws can i ask
you a question i don't know how much
time we have um but i really i i have
two kevin durant questions okay all
right
has kevin durant ever been the best
player in basketball and if so when
i've said no
i get i get into this discussion with
doug gottlieb gottlieb is like
my god lady's
no
lebron has always been better than kevin
durant
last year one could argue with lebron
getting hurt not playing great in the
playoffs that durant passed him but then
last year jan has passed them both
and and now it's honest all right here's
the next question because here's the
other thing you know how much i care
about ranking players
i feel like so
bill simmons who cares even more about
ranking players than me and wrote one of
the greatest books on basketball ever
and i have tremendous respect for he
keeps just casually saying
kd is one of the 10 greatest players
ever
i don't
not only do i not think that's right i
don't think i don't think anyone
actually thinks it if you name the names
so just walk with me here and stop me if
there's anyone you think there's an
argument katie's better than lebron
kareem michael magic wilt russell we're
at six already off the top no question
tim duncan kobe bryant larry bird
we're at nine to be top ten you have to
then be better than everyone else i have
not mentioned akeem i've not mentioned
shaq i have not mentioned dr j to me
those are three more clearly now we're
at 12 and here's the other problem for
kd
is it ridiculous for me to say he's
going to end up the fourth best
of his era
lebron
giannis steph durant
like the post like that so to me
katie's a hell of a lot closer to 20 all
time than to 10. i didn't even mention
moses i didn't mention oscar or jerry
oscar and jerry are tough and they're so
long ago i'm not gonna act like i
watched them uh but i don't think do any
of those names jump out to you as oh
that nick that's ridiculous durant's
better than that
um
i
i'd like to know who bill simmons is
taking out of the top ten
yeah i'd just be curious because at some
point
now simmons isn't taking larry bird out
of there but no but at some point
somebody's gonna make a case for
themselves that larry bird drops out of
the top 10 all time
uh
just because he didn't have longevity he
did have the you know the three mvps you
know but you might have giannis
i think yana's going to replace it yeah
right now like i think larry is a strong
nine but if you're nine you're holding
on for dear life for that top ten i have
larry right ahead of a team in shaq and
dr j what about dr jay gets screwed
because nobody cares about the aba but
he was so dominant but go ahead what
about steph curry if golden state wins a
title this year
to me steph curry would would then does
he move ahead i know people love to say
he was never mvp of the of the finals i
understand all that but if he wins a
title without kd
uh do we then put him higher on that
list
yeah i think if he wins the title this
year
he jumps moses and dr j
and i think you start having a real
conversation it's so funny couldn't have
two more dissimilar players of him and
shaq
i've always been in the team a slightly
ahead of shaq guy
um
but then it's a real like shaq and steph
couldn't be you know more diametrically
opposed players
but i think it's a real conversation
they would have the same number of rings
i'm not count the rings guy they would
have gotten them very differently
um
shaq's all-time apex might be the
highest if you were to tell me one game
to save your life you get any player in
league history it is apex i think i
might take shaq over lebron kareem and
mike like apec shaq i'm like well i'm
getting 40 and 20 and five like
guaranteed but he just didn't wasn't
there long enough and steph it has to if
the goal is winning
it has to be accounted for this guy's
the greatest teammate this side of tim
duncan we've seen in 30 years that he
welcomed durant in that he is now saying
i'll come off the bench when you need me
that like that stuff has to matter
yeah i i still look at you know there's
certain guys that i look like look at
and say they're underrated like i think
elijah won is underrated i i i mean to
me he's a player ever he's my favorite
doesn't he
he still leads in block shots all time
of course
he's up there in steals as well yeah of
course yeah and people don't the thing
is nobody knows dude went to the finals
in 86. nobody cares about that um lost
to one of the greatest teams ever in the
celtics and then
the next year in the playoffs
average i don't have it in front of me
but in a series they lost in the first
round averaged like 37 and 17 with four
blocks a game they losing round one
a team was and it has to matter that for
everyone's like oh michael would have
won eight i don't buy that but
there was an era
of barkley malone ewing
robinson you know because duncan wasn't
there yet all payton kemp
your buddy reggie miller all these guys
had two not zero one and a half
non-michael jordan championships
eligible for him young shaq
and akeem got them both
that's gotta matter no i a dream is
unbelievable unbelievable and the
greatest defensive player other than
bill russell in nba history and having
been fortunate to to watch dr j in two
aba games
and i i remember
that he played against denver and denver
had a great front line
but dr j was there nobody'd like him
like
but people can't see that like you can
see
but oh my god and he wasn't a great
shooter
but he just he had this you know go back
to the portland series against bill
walton
he was the best player they should have
given him the mvp
in a losing effort
and here's the thing about two things
about dr j broussard brings this up all
the time he's right when the aba and the
nba both existed and the aba and the nba
would play each other in exhibitions the
aba won two out of three ever so you
could argue the aba was tougher he's the
greatest player in aba history then he
goes to the nba
and before he wins the title with moses
he took the sixers to three finals so
the sixers to three like no dr j this
this everyone just
it felt like
three years ago elevated durant ahead of
dr j and it's just
like pump the brakes a bit
a little a little bit i i think we all
thought it's just unbelievable to me
i was in person at barclays to watch the
greatest game durants ever played 48 17
and 10
with the harden on one leg no kyrie game
five against milwaukee
that's the last playoff game he won
that's tough
if i say in the last 20 years you got
one guy to start franchise with and i
remove lebron
be honest
okay do you think he's gonna be a top
five player of all time
well the top five is hard
top five is a tough one to crack because
there's like it's
you know it's the four most important
transcendent players in league history
lebron cream magic and michael and then
you know pick pick wilt or russell
whatever your flavor is so i don't know
if you want it
so you really only have i
i don't know
i don't know if he's gonna be top five
all the time i do think he's gonna pass
kobe
and duncan and bird
i think i mean i think he's gonna win
this year
i mean he's unbelievable i think that
for the next eight years in the nba it's
giannis and luca
and it's it's the 2020s version of bird
and magic it's not just because white
black and east west but i i i luca is
i you know i see
you know i i'm the man that said the
clippers could never make the conference
funds with flying paul george and that
said the nets could never make the
conference finals i'm also a man said
the mavs are going to make the finals
you mark that down damn patrick this is
lucas 07 level i know i know you've been
you've been big on them they got
survive this series
oh it's over surviving the series i by
the way i'm i'm moving markets
the the vegas has underpriced the mavs
consistently since luke has been back
and this morning i log in like oh dallas
plus a point and a half well that seems
worth a maximum wager mentioning on the
show show ends i look oh dallas minus
one old two and a half point line
movement was there any news no no they
saw your buddy nick wright put in a
wager and they were like oh boy he's
been killing us on the lucas up it was
dallas minus three yesterday dan
paid for a small mid-sized luxury sedan
with that i like that and next meal on
me oh yeah wagyu yeah oh boy i've been
i've been looking
i've been looking uh give my best to
wilde
okay i'll give my i'll give your best to
everyone on my show since you liked all
of us equally i'll talk to you later all
right thank you bud that's nick wright
fox uh sports first things first fs1
we'll take a break back after this